do they look at North Korea that if you
have a kid it's the country's kids is
that kind of how they view it it's a
collective it's an hours our Keepers
it's not yours of course not we cannot
say I you know there's no I wow yeah
like there are people you can say I feel
this no so I like water no you really
like water we like kimchi we like
barbecue
very important to understand you can't
even use the word I I am happy no I want
to go to the park today so what is it
just me we are happy we want to go to
the park dude yes not very bizarre oh
dude and the Loyalty leads to individual
yeah competition among individuals
winners and losers oh we can't have that
in communism
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]